le stade ultramoderne de munich envahit
peu à peu par les supporteurs c'est là
que la france sera opposée au portugal
dans une heure pour une place en finale
du mondial et dans une ambiance
apparemment très bon enfant nous y
consacrerons une grande partie de ce
journal dont voici les titres d'abord la
composition du onze français n'a pas
encore été livrée par raymond domenech
mais on attend la même formation avec
thierry henry en seul attaquant de
pointe du conseil des ministres vedette
de cinéma en passant par les foules
massées devant les écrans géants un peu
partout c'est tout le pays qui se
passionne pour le match nous serons en
direct tout au long de cette édition
avec marseille paris lisbonne et bien
sûr munich hier soir dans la première
demi-finale l'italien a arraché une
qualification méritée face à l'allemagne
dans les dernières minutes d arrêts de
jeu nous irons aussi à rome autre
actualité de cette journée le déficit le
défi de la corée du nord elle a procédé
au tir d'essai de sept missiles malgré
les mises en garde
plus qu'un réel danger les experts y
voient une provocation destinée à
relancer les négociations sur le
nucléaire
les orages ont fait deux morts en france
deux ouvriers d'un chantier tuées par la
foudre dans le cantal
l' alerte reste maintenue ce soir dans
onze départements du nord-est
enfin le tour de france toujours aux
mains des sprinteurs deuxième victoire
pour l'australien robbie mcewen tom
boonen reste maillot jaune bonsoir à
tous après francfort après hanovre s'est
donc à munich que la france a rendez
vous avec son aventure en coupe du monde
une fois encore il fait très chaud et
une fois encore c'est un rituel très
précis qui a été observé pour cette
journée de matchs promenade sieste
collation et dernières consignes de
l'entraîneur
l'équipe est arrivée au stade il ya
quelques minutes sur place les dernières
images de nos envoyés spéciaux manuel
tissier vincent bouffartigue depuis plus
de 20 ans ans portugais allait toujours
un match brûlant
pourquoi plus que jamais peut-être les
plus de vous garder la tête froide dans
la chaleur écrasante de l'unique ce
matin ils sont allés chercher un peu de
fraîcheur et de détente à deux pas de
leur hôtel en plein centre ville depuis
la fin du premier tour
les tricolores dégage une impression de
sérénité imperméable au doute
sûrs de leur force mais sans arrogance
ce soir le portugal n'est qu'une étape
sur le chemin qu'ils ont tracée pour
arriver au 9 juillet il faut être
performant ce match là et y aura besoin
d'être encore plus performant que les
autres matches ce que l'adversaire est
solide mais il est arrivé aussi en demi
finale et c'est pas un hasard parce que
c'est parce qu'il a du talent les bleus
ont repéré hier soir l'allianz arena
théâtre de cette demi finale
aujourd'hui après une dernière séance
vidéo ils sont entrés de plain-pied dans
la rencontre
les portugais ne feront pas de cadeaux
le défi physique risque de rythme et le
match au niveau de l'intensité y aura
beaucoup d'intensité mais bon j'espère
qu'il y aura pas trop de en valeur de
kouba c'est vrai qu'avant tous le
football reste un jeu il vous faudra
être loyal si on peut dire derrière les
vitres fumées
certains ont monté le son casque sur les
oreilles zidane est au fond du bus comme
d'habitude voici les bleus il entre dans
l'arène pour un nouvel exploit
bonsoir manuel il ya quelques secondes
la composition de l'équipe de france
vient d'être donné c'est bien celle qui
a gagné contre le brésil et l'espagne
qui est reconduite
oui vous connaissez la fameuse formule
on ne change pas une équipe qui gagne la
france a gagné deux fois donc raymond
domenech reconduit la même formule à
savoir un seul attaquant devant avec
thierry henry puis trois milieux de
terrain que l'on qualifiera d'offensif
au tour de zinedine zidane dans laxe
franck ribéry et florent malouda est
bien sûr derrière les deux chiens de
garde de la défense patrick vieira et
claude makelele et une défense inchangée
avec évidemment fabien barthez dans les
bleus il est évident que raymond
domenech veut réitérer les deux
performances qu'il a réussi à produire à
faire produire à ses joueurs contre le
brésil espagne à savoir sa cuisine
particulière sa cuisine à l'étouffée qui
empêche les joueurs de jouer les joueurs
adverses je jouais bien sûr et de
développer leur football et comment est
l'ambiance sur place manuel et dans le
stade plutôt tendues entre les
supporters ou plutôt bon enfant comme un
fin d'après midi
non c'est une atmosphère très bon enfant
les supporters portugais comme les
supporters français ne sont pas connus
pour leur excès bien au contraire les
portugais avaient organisé un formidable
euros il y a deux ans dans leur pays
et ce sont des gens des portes des
supporters qui aiment faire la fête et
qui sont évidemment très proche des
français donc on s'attend à une belle
fête sur le terrain mais aussi en
tribunes
merci manuel on vous retrouvera à la fin
de ce journal alors précisément voyons
tout de suite comment dans les rangs
français on appréhende ce match
reportage au côté des supporteurs
français avec une autre de nos équipes
sur place emmenée par christophe
schneider et jean pierre pasteur
à quelques heures du match les français
mais déjà l'ambiance le centre ville de
munich appartient aux bleus ses
supporters ont suivi toute la saga
tricolore pas question d'en rester là on
est sûr de gagner un peu d'eau le
brésilien est comme les espagnols
pour eux la victoire est acquise le
score aussi
zéro par la branche monuc de zidane
ribéry puis enrichi 3 prenant pas en
arrière ça dans sa chance et la fête
dans la rue de bonheur et partager les
français fraternisent avec les portugais
et on n'hésite pas à se titiller
on a bâti les breillat et portugais on a
peut-être dîner pente et alors réponse
après le match
en attendant un seul mot d'ordre oui on
peut s'en étonner ou s'en féliciter en
tout cas seuls aujourd'hui le football
créé une telle communion dans les
villages ou dans les grandes villes des
dizaines d'écrans géants ont été
installés un peu partout comme ici à
toulouse place du capitole
à l'opposé du territoire à strasbourg
c'est sur la place de l'étoile que les
alsaciens sont en train de se retrouver
pour assister au match malgré les
risques d'orages des couvertures ont été
posés à terre et des stands proposent le
fameux maquillage bleu blanc rouge sur
les visages image aussi de boulogne
c'est sur le bord de mer à côté du port
que la mairie a installé un écran géant
boulogne c'est la ville de franck ribéry
la révélation française de cette coupe
du monde enfin nous allons à marseille
bonsoir zine dine boudaoud
vous êtes sur le vieux port où tout le
monde se retrouve pour assister au match
là bas c'est zidane qu'on va suivre
particulièrement j'imagine bonsoir david
bienvenus à marseille la capitale du
foot français car si paris est la
capitale administrative et politique du
pays
on ne prend pas beaucoup de risques en
disant que c'est ici que le coeur du
foot français bas alors à moins d'une
heure du coup d'envoi
plusieurs centaines de marseillais sont
déjà arrivés ici sur le vieux port où je
me trouve où un écran géant a été
installé
les supporters que nous avons rencontrés
tout à l'heure avec un peu de
chauvinisme et beaucoup d'enthousiasmé
n'ont pas manqué de nous rappeler que
barthez et ribéry étaient des joueurs de
l'om mais ici comme vous le disiez david
à marseille un numéro 10 le capitaine
zinedine zidane est adulé vénéré n'ayons
pas peur des mots à marseille personne
n'a parié un pastis sur la victoire des
portugais écouter david
c'est obligé
j'ai peur des portugais mais j'ai jaguar
faire cinq minutes seulement au bout de
six minutes c'est bourial sommes bien
plus tôt oui je pense à la phrase ça lui
aussi se sont en deuil pour lyon69 et
puis en attendant que le meilleur gagne
petite note un petit peu de prudence la
semaine dernière après la qualification
de la france contre le brésil quelques
incidents ont éclaté du coup la
préfecture de police de marseille a
décidé de déployer à peu près 300
policiers autour du vieux-port david
merci on espère que ça va être la fête
d'eysines dean ce soir s'il fallait en
tout cas une autre illustration de la
fièvre qui saisit la france est
peut-être chez les vendeurs de maillots
et de drapeaux qu'il faut aller la
chercher
les magasins ont été dévalisés le mot
n'est pas trop fort reportage nicolas
lemarignier frédéric de la rue de france
anticipe pour lionel dupont et sa bande
c'était la boutique de la dernière
chance
les maillots les drapeaux les écharpes à
montbéliard on ne trouve plus rien
épuisement du stock que la purée chou
blanc à chaque fois chaud dans la
panoplie du supporter ça n'est pas
vraiment compliqué c'est la perruque
tricolore c'est le maquillage évidemment
c'est la corne de supporters pour faire
beaucoup de bruit
eux ont trouvé dans cette boutique
parisienne pour les retardataires c'est
la désolation été dévalisée reste plus
rien donc
et ça donc c'est le pouvoir c'est pour
mon petit-fils de ciseaux qui vit aux
etats-unis c'est important quand même
avec un peu de patience on finit quand
même par trouver ce que l'on cherche
accessoires favori le drapeau bon je
suis d'origine camerounaise et moi ça
devenait site est liée aux français
quand tu es supporter l'équipe de france
et je mets mon drapeau aussi devant chez
moi
en règle générale la panoplie du
supporter ça n'est pas donné mais ça
n'arrête pas les ardeurs des clients et
vous en avez pour combien ça fait 50
euros et les charges ça fait tilt
inutile de dire que la vendeuse se
frotte les mains ça va on s'en sort sa
garde le commerce est vrai et puisqu'il
en faut pour tous les goûts bons et
mauvais avec 106 y du mondial
voilà donc pour celle d'un portugais ce
qu elle portait même si je perds je suis
gagnant et le drapeau pour l'instant
impossible de départager les supporters
ils sont gonflés à bloc
quel que soit le résultat l'après match
risque d'être agitée et des drapeaux et
des maillots on imagine qu'il y en a
beaucoup autour de vous claude sans
faire vous êtes au stade charléty où là
aussi un écran géant a été installé
effectivement la tension monte ici au
stade charléty un stade qui se remplit
peu à peu qu'il ait pas encore tout à
fait plein mais vous savez qu'on attend
ici 35000 personnes c'est un chiffre
considérable et l'ambiance vous
l'entendez alors il ya une demi heure à
peu près on s'est promené avec mady
diawara au mieux cette foulée ce qui
nous a frappés c'est de voir des gens de
toutes générations
beaucoup de parents sont venus ici avec
leurs enfants
on croise aussi beaucoup de jeunes
femmes des jeunes femmes passionnés de
football
et comme en 98 on croise une france très
coloré black blanc beur et si vous me
permettez l'expression ce soir black
blanc beur et portugaise parce que cette
communauté on oublie souvent c'est ce
soir il ya beaucoup de supporters
portugais qui sont là au côté pronostics
tout le monde bien évidemment on voit
une victoire de la france mais en même
temps pour être tout à fait honnête on
sent ici une véritable angoisse parce
que cette équipe du portugal fait peur
merci claude on vous retrouvera
également la fin de ce journal les
hommes et les femmes politiques eux
aussi affichent leur passion pour le
parcours de l'équipe de france le sujet
était sur toutes les lèvres ce matin
après le conseil des ministres et les
nuques philippe chasselas voilà un
supporters vernis dominique de villepin
sera tout à l'heure dans les tribunes à
munich les yeux sur les bleus certes pas
de ne pas faire le voyage pour rien
le président la république est bien
pensé
et le pays tout entier jeu nicolas
sarkozy il reste à paris pour gérer
l'après match truqué
de travail et que je veux surtout
veiller à ce que des choses se passent
bien
dans un cas comme dans un autre
principale préoccupation pour les autres
ministres aujourd'hui le résultat
victoire de survie qu'on avait les
meilleurs personne ne peut battre le
sport national pronostiqué majorité
opposition ne sont toujours pas d'accord
peut durer
allez encore un 2 0 pour la france bien
ça va être serré jusqu'au bout mais je
pense que ou à la fin du match ou en
prolongation et les syndicats se laisse
aller à la surenchère
si on veut du spectaculaire on va dire 3
2 pour la france écran géant dans les
jardins de l'assemblée tous les
personnels sont conviés avec un seul mot
d'un bon allez la france
bref toute la france politique se doit
ce soir de rouler pour les bleus oué
soirée de fête donc pour la france soir
être fait aussi pour les portugais de
france qui affichent les couleurs de
leur pays aux efforts franck genauzeau
samuel humaine c'est un des fiefs des
supporters portugais paris 15e dans une
heure les joueurs entrent sur la pelouse
le patron balle rappelle les employés
dressent les tables au bar on est un peu
tendue
la pression monte oui l'équipe de france
est une grande équipe qui seront gelés
par les doigts devant l'équipe de france
pour ceux qui n'ont pas la télé
il reste radio alfa c'est la principale
radio portugaise en france le match sera
retransmis en version originale manuel
alexandre est le seul journaliste aux
sportifs de la rédaction il sait que ses
auditeurs sont partagés je pense que à
l'heure du match le leur coeur et sera
vraiment enfin brive il sera quand même
plus rouge et vert cette couleur la
famille figueiredo manquera peut-être le
début de la rencontre
leur stand de charcuterie restant
normalement ouverts jusqu'à 21h pour eux
le match sera une sorte de soulagement 0
vous allez rentrer les bars commence à
se remplir
dans une heure ce sera plein à craquer
les portiques et de paris sont prêts à
vibrer et que dire alors de l'ambiance
là-bas au portugal le drapeau rouge et
vert et le maillot grenat sont accrochés
à toutes les fenêtres dans la foule à
lisbonne nos envoyés spéciaux yann
frontier flipper pourront aussi
retrouver quelques français voici le
reportage dans les ruelles populaire du
vieux lisbonne
les drapeaux verts et rouges claque au
vent ils ont remplacé le linge qui sèche
habituellement sur ses balcons
certes quelques irréductibles font comme
si de rien n'était oh pas de leurs
portes ces femmes font griller leur
sardines loin de la foule et de la
frénésie qui l'accompagnent
pas un frein en centre ville sont
rencontrés des supporters portugais de
tout âge fiers de leurs couleurs et sûrs
de leur victoire
nous sommes les meilleurs le portugal
est la meilleure équipe du monde et
c'est très important de les soutenir ça
leur donne car de force plus de courage
et plus de coeur le portugal va gagner
dans cette ville toute acquise à son
équipe une poignée d'envahisseurs
gaulois malicieux ils n'ont pas hésité à
revêtir leur maillot tricolore le
portugal il va gagner 2 0 quelques
regards un peu noir on a su mieux
maillot globalement
à lisbonne à quelques heures du coup
d'envoi les aficionados portugais sont
partout et quel que soit le résultat de
ce soir
il estime avoir gagné la partie comme le
dit le slogan affiché aux quatre coins
de la ville en tant que supporters nous
sommes déjà les champions du monde
bonson ryan frontier vous êtes en direct
à lisbonne en france on parle
d'engouement mais on a le sentiment
qu'au portugal la passion est encore
beaucoup beaucoup plus forte à je peux
vous dire que si l'ambiance est
incroyable à paris elle l'est au stade
charléty par exemple ou encore à
marseille
ici l'atmosphère est exceptionnelle et
c'est un tout petit pays de 10 millions
d'habitants
on a l'impression qu'à 80% 90% des
habitants
vous le voyez derrière moi qu'ils
soutiennent leur équipe nationale
tout le monde a revêtu son tact tenue
rouge et verte
ça va les petits enfants de quelques
semaines qu'ils ont sur les épaules de
leurs parents aux vieilles dames des
ruelles populaire du centre de lisbonne
que nous avons vu tout à l'heure vous
savez que les portugais ils veulent
absolument tenir leur revanche ce soir
ils ont perdu deux fois lors de l'euro
84 l'euro 2000 côtoyé français et ce
soir eh bien ils veulent gagner tout
simplement
et juste pour finir je voulais vous
montrer les gros titres de la presse
populaire de la presse tabloïd
voilà celui ci ojogo on va plus mais le
poulet français voilà a bola le grand
quotidien sportif
c'est l'équivalent de l'équipe ou ici au
portugal à la conquête de berlin on peut
y lire
et enfin avec deco ici l'un des joueurs
les plus
habile de cette sélection nationale en
couverture c'est un bien c'est un jour
par don magique nous dit ce journal
voilà je vais vous dire qu'ici et bien
il ya véritablement de l'enthousiasmé et
de l'envié est en tout cas ils sont sûrs
qu'ils vont gagner d'ici quelques heures
merci à nous on revient en france et on
va voir que le pouvoir d'attraction de
cette coupe du monde va bien au delà des
fanas de football ainsi les vedettes de
cinéma ou de la chanson se bousculent
pour assister au match
l'une de nos équipes a pu embarquer à
bord d'un des avions privés qui a fait
le déplacement ce soir celui de l'homme
d'affaires jean claude darmon l'un des
plus fervents supporters des bleus qui a
emmené quelques invités reportages
pascal stelletta avec loïc de la mornais
c'est l'histoire d'une virée entre
supporteurs tendance jet setteur
aéroport du bourget 15 heures
aujourd'hui
jean claude darmon l'inventeur du
marketing sportif affrète un vol privé
pour munich en compagnie de richard
berry tchéky karyo michèle laroque et
d'autres règles
tous fans de foot des places arrière
jusqu'au cockpit le maillot le dit cela
bien sûr il est plus difficile de
discuter football avec le bruit
assourdissant des réacteurs
mais cela n'en commode pas nos stars
amoureuse du ballon rond pronostic de
match à dix mille mètres d'altitude
duguay
très belle équipe
oui
près du très luxueux zh truqueurs à la
base
mais je pense qu'ils ne pensent
complètement sereine parce qu'on fait
vous revenez pour la finale
si je peux téléphoner
quoi qu'il arrive la troupe fêtera la
victoire ou pleurera la défaite en plein
ciel puisque elle repartira aux douze
coups de minuit dans son jet privé
et puis cette image à propos de
personnalités saisis sur le vif dans les
rues de munich en fin d'après midi
il s'agit du célèbre réalisateur
américain spike lee avec son fils vous
avez bien vu il porte le maillot bleu de
l'équipe de france spike lee est un ami
proche de thierry henry la france vous
le savez est considérée comme favorite
car elle n'a pas été battu par les
portugais depuis une trentaine d'années
le parcours des deux équipes a mis en
évidence les points forts des uns et des
autres romain mais si c'est une évidence
pour arriver en demi finale et
multiplier les joies collectives d'après
match la france et le portugal ont été
très forts ce soir le face à face promet
des étincelles
les portugais n'ont encaissé qu'un seul
but face au mexicain parole est donnée à
la défense elle n'a jamais été prise en
faute une deuxième fois derrière elle le
gardien ricardo est un dernier rempart
efficace avec 3 tirs au but à arrêter
les anglais sont repartis écoeuré
mais il ya aussi les artistes figo déco
cristiano ronaldo sont omniprésents pour
faire sauter les défenses adverses
seul pauleta attend depuis quatre
matches le but qui ne vient toujours pas
moins glamour mais tout aussi efficace
le portugal est le plus fort pour faire
perdre ses nerfs à son adversaire
face à lui l'angleterre ou les pays bas
ont fini le match à 10 les français sont
prévenus
fébrile durant le premier tour la
défense française n'est plus la même
les espagnols ont eu besoin d'un penalty
pour trouver la faille
quant aux stars brésiliennes elles se
sont heurtées en quart de finale un mur
bleu blanc rouge mais la métamorphose
française est venue de ses leaders
zidane sans égal face au brésil maîtres
du ballon rond henri décisif face aux
mêmes brésiliens
sans oublier ribéry la révélation
tricolore qui a soufflé la révolte face
à l'espagne seul ombre au tableau il 106
déjà averti à redouter ce soir un carton
jaune qui les priverait de finale
parmi eux 10 dan qu'on a surtout pas
envie de voir à la retraite avant
l'heure voilà on reviendra tout à
l'heure sur le football et cette demi
finale nous irons notamment guadeloupe
et au stade charléty nous reviendrons
aussi sur la première est magnifique
demi finale qui a vu la victoire de
l'italie hier soir sur l'allemagne
d'abord le reste de l'actualité avec la
crispation autour de la corée du nord
qui a procédé comme elle l'avait annoncé
aux tirs d'essai de sept missiles
il s'agit d'une provocation mais pas
vraiment d'une menace selon les experts
une provocation qui s'inscrit dans la
partie d'échecs engagé avec les états
unis sur le nucléaire
gilles rabin jarret tir de missile n'a
été aussi délibérément politique le jour
choisi d'abord le 4 juillet jour de la
fête de l'indépendance américaine
le nombre de missiles en suisse est dont
l'un des tout nouveaux missiles
nord-coréens à longue portée capable en
théorie de toucher l'alaska ou à hawaï
un véritable feu d'artifice l'endroit où
ils se sont abîmés enfin au milieu de la
mer du japon
ce qui a fait dire aux responsables
américains qui ne s'agissait pas d'une
menace mais d'une provocation la nation
unanime dans le monde aux états unis au
japon qui se sent directement disait en
europe en russie comme en chine même si
celle ci se montre que timide
le conseil de sécurité de l'onu a été
saisie en urgence
le dictateur nord-coréen et donc passer
outre les mises en garde de ces derniers
jours il veut obtenir le même traitement
que l'iran ce qu'on lui refuse comme
l'iran il veut recevoir des pays
occidentaux une offre constructive de
négociations sur le nucléaire et pouvoir
discuter directement avec les américains
le dictateur nord-coréen est habitué à
tester les limites c'est la diplomatie
du faible au fort
un jeu dangereux voit chaque instant il
risque de se brûler les mains
en bref encore à l'étranger le mexique
attend toujours de connaître
officiellement le nom de son prochain
président un nouveau décompte de
l'ensemble des voix est en cours pour
départager le conservateur felipe
calderon qui aurait 400 mille voix
400000 suffrages davance et le candidat
de gauche andres lopez obrador qui ne
veut pas reconnaître sa défaite et
dénonce des fraudes
en espagne la station de métro jesús à
valence où sont morts quarante et une
personnes dans le déraillement d'une
rame a rouvert ses portes et les usagers
étaient peu nombreux ce matin dans une
ville qui est encore choqué des bouquets
de fleurs ont été déposées aux entrées
de la station est par ailleurs une
polémique est en train de se développer
sur la carence du système d'alarmé censé
prévenir une défaillance humaine en
france l' alerte aux orages est
maintenue dans une partie de l'est de la
france la foudre a provoqué la mort de
deux ouvriers qui travaillaient sur un
chantier dans le cantal
aurélia guillemin bernard bonnart voilà
ce qui tombait sur la toiture alors
c'est certain
il a suffi de quelques minutes pour que
la grêle ravages de nombreux toits des
environs et depuis ce matin les
véhicules endommagés se compte par vous
là un véhicule devant là il ya une bosse
je pense que c'est un grêlon qu'il
devait faire 15 kg qui attendait dessus
dans l'oise c'est la foudre qui a frappé
heureusement pas des victimes dans cette
maison mais des dégâts matériels
impressionnant en picardie les pompiers
sont intervenus 700 fois hier soir
ici c'est le toit du supermarché qui
s'est en partie effondré l'eau est bien
peser trop fort sur la structure et puis
donc fait céder le tout la toiture l'eau
a aussi surpris les habitants de
plusieurs communes champenoise dans ce
quartier les égouts engorgé par la boue
ont débordé royaume au minimum 10 cm
d'eau dans cette maison il ya des mecs
ça à plat pied ya des morts partout elle
a un enfant de 10 mois et demi eh ben je
sais pas comment ils montèrent 1800
hectares de vignes endommagé dans la
marne de nombreux arbres arrachés près
de limoges trois cent mille foyers
français momentanément privés
d'électricité
l'orage dévastateur dans plusieurs
régions a aussi été meurtrier
dans le cantal deux ouvriers qui
travaillaient sur un chantier ont été
foudroyées et l' alerte orange et
finalement étendue à une grande moitié
est ce soir 31 départements exactement
des ardennes à la drôme prudence donc si
vous devez circuler
l' alerte à la canicule elle est
définitivement levé justice la fameuse
affaire des hlm de paris qui a ébranlé
le rpr pendant plusieurs années s'est
finalement soldé aujourd'hui par des
condamnations à des peines de prison
avec sursis et des amendes pour les
intermédiaires les chefs d'entreprise et
les responsables de l'office hlm qui
était jugée 37 condamnations au total et
es11 relaxe les résultats du bac
les statistiques sont sortis les
ordinateurs et le taux de réussite cette
année pour ce qu'ils ont obtenu du
premier coup et tout simplement un
record près de 74 % ces cinq points de
mieux que l'an passé si nabila taboury
michael carillon de quoi être
impressionné
agathe vient de décrocher son bac
économique et social avec mention bien
serait-elle une exception eh bien pas du
tout le cru 2010 du baccalauréat
s'annonce même exceptionnel dans la
filière générale 73,9 %
soit trois candidats sur quatre ont
décroché leur diplôme du premier coup
l'an dernier ils n'étaient que 68 des
vues vie pour ça après de longues
semaines de blocages liés au cpe élèves
parents et professeurs avaient pourtant
des craintes
du coup le s'interroge sur sa valeur je
pense que et les élèves et les
professeurs ont fait ce qu'il fallait
pour rattraper dans leur mois dans le
mois et demi qui restait donc non non je
pense que le bloc n'a pas été donnée ni
plus simple ni plus compliqué premiers à
bénéficier de ses bons résultats les
bacheliers scientifiques
il faut maintenant attendre la fin du
rattrapage pour confirmer ces chiffres
en général près de huit candidats sur 10
décrochent le bac après les oraux c'est
plutôt de bonne augure
un accident mortel au parc astérix à un
garçon de 6 ans s'est noyé dans une
rivière artificielle il participait à
une attraction sur un bateau il est
tombé après avoir été déséquilibré il
faisait partie d'un groupe d'une
centaine d'enfants venus d'un centre
aéré de belgique
les cendres d'alfred dreyfus ne seront
finalement pas transférer au panthéon
jacques chirac a fait le choix d'une
cérémonie nationale pour les 100 ans de
la réhabilitation du soldat cérémonie
qui se déroulera le 12 juillet en
présence du président de la république à
l'école militaire à paris
le tour de france toujours aux mains des
sprinteurs deuxième victoire pour robbie
mcewen
tom boonen est toujours en jaune dans le
peloton et sur les bords de la route on
a aussi beaucoup entendu parler de
football
nathanaël de rincquesen patrick desmulie
il finit comme un avant goût de coupe du
monde aujourd'hui sur les routes du tour
les héros du peloton avec la compagnie
zidane et l'équipe de france était là
sur les bas côtés tout au long des 207
km du parcours
peut-être galvanisé par la réussite des
bleus en allemagne trois français
prennent part à l'échappée du jour
mangel lefebvre et coutouly sont
accompagnés de martinez eyvigues hills
dès le 20e kilomètre de l'étape les cinq
hommes engagent un véritable bras de fer
avec le peloton 180 kilomètres
d'échappée
hier les équipiers des sprinteurs
donnent la chasse le peloton lancé comme
un cheval au galop rattrape les fuyards
à moins de deux kilomètres de l'arrivée
c'est le peloton aussi télé si les
échappés vont pourquoi mais bon c'est
vrai que face à ces faits vraiment sur
le sur le final est sur la ligne de
saint quentin
l'ambiance monte les supporters de
l'équipe de france attend impatiemment
l'arrivée de l'étape est votre pronostic
avec un peu de chance ce spectateur s'y
connaît plus en football quand cyclisme
à saint quentin c'est mcewen qui
s'imposent
un sprint marqué par la chute du
néo-zélandais julian dean le maillot
jaune de tom boonen lui ne tient plus
qu'à une seconde et on y revient
précisément la coupe du monde hier vous
le savez elles l'italie offensive
méritante s'est qualifié pour la finale
un match intense et beaucoup de suspense
puisque les deux buts de la victoire ont
été inscrits dans les toutes dernières
minutes des prolongations christophe
duchiron jérôme boni s'est vaguement
comme un gros chagrin qui fait mal au
coeur et en dépit des apparences moins
pire qu'un drame national
heureusement d'ailleurs ce n'est qu'une
histoire de foot certes un peu triste
pour l'allemagne où les mouchoirs vont
sortir après les drapeaux à leurs
joueurs qui ont versé de la sueur et
maintenant des larmes les supporters
rendre un hommage lacrymal remarquer
pour se mettre dans des états pareils il
y a des raisons que la raison ignore
parfois 00 début des prolongations mais
par deux fois l'allemagne a senti le
vent du ballon lui siffler aux oreilles
gilardino sur le poteau elie minutes
plus tard zambrotta sur la barre
le temps passe c'est la réponse du
berger allemand la bergère italienne
podolski de la tête à côté encore
podolski il tire à vue sur bouffonne le
gardien italien qui détourne au cours
d'un match d'une grande intensité les
blancs ont mouillé le maillot et les
yeux de l'art de leurs supporteurs pris
que deux minutes à jouer à l'e3 le
moment des tirs au but que les allemands
coupe du monde ne perdent jamais au
contraire des italiens les italiens dont
la défense est un coffre fort remarquée
grâce à brosseau le premier but du match
à la 118e minute de jeu
pour finir en beauté l'italie ajoute un
dernier but sur une pichenette de del
piero victoire 2 à 0
un triomphe transalpin en terre
allemande les supporters d'outre-rhin
n'ont pas supporté dans les têtes c'est
la misère sur les visages désole la
désillusion mais ça passera
oui et l'équipe d'allemagne a tout de
même était acclamé à son retour à
l'hôtel pour les allemands et malgré
cette défaite ce mondial restera un
souvenir formidable car ils ont renoué
avec leurs drapeaux et avec l'idée de
patriotisme en italie au contraire on a
fêté la victoire très tard dans la nuit
un peu comme en france personne
n'imaginait l'équipe allait aussi loin
car le début de la compétition avait été
laborieux à rome gérard griesbeck karine
guillaume a rarement la nuit romaine
haïti si chaude il a fallu attendre les
premières lueurs du jour pour que la
capitale retrouve un peu de sérénité
il faut dire que la victoire était nette
mais un peu tardive pour des nerv
supporters rassemblés devant des écrans
géants dans le centre de rome
alain a glané fait un grand match avec
lippi un grand entraîneur des grands
joueurs tels piero qui était magique
c'est fantastique
pourtant la victoire a pris son temps
beaucoup de temps
une première période puis gilles
deuxième vie les prolongations sur l'
angoisse que seule version les visages
les verts la petite faim la délivrance
voilà
ça fait tellement de bien timide et
après ça recommence
c'était vraiment trop beau il m'a
tellement super on empiète lui
finalement on est en finale
visible c'est sûr on va gagner pour la
libye qui va prendre notre revanche de
l'euro 2000
les titres de la presse ressemble
aujourd'hui à des billets d'amour pour
une équipe tant décriée au début du
mondial et qui maintenant c'est normal
se voit déjà en haut de la fiche
alors qui va affronter l'italie en
finale la france ou le portugal réponse
dans trois heures on l'a dit c'est tout
un pays qui soutient les bleus exemple
au camping de palavas-les-flots
reportage hélène verne pascal fons seul
cri de ralliement déjà à l'heure de
l'apéro andré ses amis sont arrivés il
ya deux mois et n'a manqué aucun match
alors celui de ce soir les des amis le
drapeau sur la voiture donc on va gagner
c'est sûr alors que c'est quoi que ce
soit parce que j'ai joué trente ans au
rugby valoir que celui du football et en
avait parlé de foot le foot va très bien
faute je suis je pense que ce soir la
france ont gagné
il faut dire que dans ce camping de
palavas les supporters affichent ou la
couleur pas une caravane sans la télé
jusqu aux minots qui joue la rencontre
avant l'heure pour la france va gagner
et longuement pour l'équipe de france
touche toutes les générations a commencé
par lise est une habituée ma petite j'ai
deux télévisions
j'en ai une grande la grande banque
comme ça là une petite course à damas
car moi je vais être que mon pote c'est
demain pour la france même si je pense
que le portugal super dur à battre mais
fait croire au bar d'autres pensent déjà
à une finale france italie
je vous donner la dimension du mas va
pas être simple puisque drapeau déjà
de la bonne humeur les décorations qui
s'affiche en tout cas tout est fait pour
que ce drapeau français il ne reste pas
en berne une région française est
particulièrement bien représenté dans
l'équipe un territoire il s'agit de la
guadeloupe avec notamment thierry henry
lilian thuram là bas l'après midi vient
à peine de commencer
les fans sont confiants envoyés spéciaux
martine laroche-joubert pascal jouffre
yves la guadeloupe est en vacances mais
ils vivent ici une journée particulière
la demi finale est dans tous les esprits
six joueurs de l'équipe de france
viennent de cette île des caraïbes sur
le marché de pointe à pitre la capitale
une certaine fébrilité se devine au delà
des apparences de la douceur de vivre
il voit dans leurs joueurs un miroir de
leur propre caractère pour contrôler un
petit pc 13 à 6 à 6 à ce qu'on fait j'en
ai mais là ça sera dur c'est plus vieux
que le match contre le brésil parce que
le portugal ses proches mais c'est
l'équipe qui a envie de gagner mais
chacun semble connaître ici les
ingrédients d'une possible victoire et
vendre fruits à pain les pâtes de tous
les habitants du pays
au delà des côtes de la guadeloupe une
petite île assoupi la désirade
elle vit au rythme des buts de l'enfant
du pays thierry henry son oncle et sa
grand mère habite y est ce que vous
regardez tous les matches
vous la regardez pas
pourquoi daniel henry a peur de voir son
petit fils blessé sur le terrain elle
regardera le match d'aujourd'hui en
différé la guadeloupe retient son
souffle avant cette demi finale avec une
pensée toute particulière pour ses
joueurs excepté devant les télévisions
et les grands écrans le pays va tourner
au ralenti d'ici une vingtaine de
minutes c'est déjà le cas aux champs
elysées à paris qui se vide peu à peu
tout simplement
et bien parce que la circulation des
voitures il sera totalement interdite
d'ici quelques minutes
en cas de victoire cinq cent mille à un
million de personnes sont attendues là
bas et un gros dispositif policier a de
nouveau été mise en place
avant de refermer ce journal ont fait un
dernier détour par munich est d'abord
par paris paris où plusieurs écrans
géants ont été installés images ici du
parc des princes on a carrément ouvert
le stade du paris saint germain au
public car il ya beaucoup beaucoup monde
qui souhaitent assister à ces rencontres
sur grand écran public déjà sur place
seront envoyés dans les tribunes par
milliers avec une ambiance bonne enfant
et puis comme c'est le cas depuis le
début des matches l'équipe de france en
8e et en quarts de finale le stade
charléty a également été ouvert au
public et on refait un tour pour
retrouver claude 100 perd on imagine
claude que cette fois c'est archi comble
s'est pas encore tout à fait quand vous
allez découvrir sur ces images mais la
tension monte la pression monte alors si
la caméra peut le quitter je vous
propose de découvrir ce stade charléty
qui continue de se remplir
on attend ainsi 35000 personnes mais
n'ayez aucun doute dans 20 à 25 minutes
c'est 35 personnel seront là parce
qu'elle était là pour le match
france-brésil et ce sera encore le cas
ce soir
et honnêtement pour avoir assisté au
match france brésil ici on est très
impressionné on est très émus quand on
voit toute cette foule ici dans ce stade
tous ces gens qui ont décidé de partager
ensemble toutes les minutes d'émotion de
ce match une france ce soir tu es très
coloré france black blanc beur comme en
une france aussi très portugais ce soir
ce qu'on voit ici quelques supporters
portugais aux ouailles et l'ambiance qui
montent beaucoup de sifflets
beaucoup d'ambiance à 20 25 minutes
maintenant du coup d'envoi merci claude
on va maintenant à munich retrouvé
manuel tissier donc à quelques vingt
minutes maintenant 25 minutes du match
le manuel qui a gagné le match des
supporters
les français ou les portugais sont les
plus nombreux dans les tribunes
pour l'instant les français sont un
petit peu plus nombreux que les
portugais c'est vrai mais cela se passe
dans le stade maintenant le match des
supporters va également commencer dans
les tribunes avec les champs dans ce
stade futuriste que les allemands
surnomment le pneu et donc il va y avoir
forcément beaucoup d'ambiance parce que
c'est un stade où les cris et les
chansons résonnent énormément donc le
spectacle devrait aussi être dans les
travées manuel est ce que vous avez des
informations sur la fameuse phrase de
ralliement des français et qui remplace
un peu la chanson i will survive qui
était un peu leurs chansons en 1998 à
vous savez david cette phrase mystère
doit rester un mystère ça fait aussi
partie de ce pacte secret que les bleus
ont liés entre eux qui est une des
explications de leur formidable envie et
de ce ciment social qui ont fait une
équipe pour l'instant imbattable vous la
connaîtrez cette phrase si vous êtes
curieux à la fin de la coupe du monde
peut-être à berlin le 9 juillet au soir
après la victoire
merci manuel on vous souhaite un bon
match c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi tout de suite la météo
isabelle martinet 20h50 un téléfilm le
roman de georges est avec charlotte kady
à demain